[Music]
i'm over violence against women not
being an international priority when you
rape
beat
maim
mutilate burn
bury and terrorize women
you destroy the essential life energy on
the planet you force what is meant to be
open trusting nurturing creative and
alive to be bent infertile and broken
night after night i heard the same
stories
women being raped as teenagers in
college
as little girls
as elderly women
what we saw
a girl drinking chemicals in the
bathroom
a girl killed by a bump
a girl beaten up with a rifle over and
over
a girl running headfirst into a wall
a girl's malnourished body damped in the
river to draw
i didn't wouldn't intervene
she was
he is unwritten law
i'm over rape
i'm over rape happening in broad
daylight
i'm over rape culture rape mentality
i am over rape victims becoming re-raped
when they go public i'm over
women still being silent about rape
because they are made to believe it's
their fault
no women
no future
da
i'm over the passivity of good men where
the hell are you
you live with us make love with us
father us
befriend us
brother us
get nurtured and mothers and eternally
supported by us
so why aren't you driven to madness and
action by the rape and humiliation of us
when you break the silence
you realize
how many other people were waiting for
permission to do the same thing
[Music]
we
every thought and type of woman
every single one of us and our vaginas
will never
be silenced again
we need to occupy rape in every school
park radio tv station household office
factory refugee camp military base back
room nightclub alleyway courtroom un
office because we are over it
[Music]
you